I had thyroid cancer, and I assumed I had Hashimoto's before that.
I've been hypothyroid for many years in a scintoroid.
I had surgery last year to remove the nodules in my thyroid.
Since they were large, I also had radiation.
I've had stomach issues most of my life, so several years ago I went plant-based,
which helped.
Now it seems that I might have been related to my thyroid.
Since my surgery, my endocrinologist is also what we had a gluten-free diet.
Now that I have no longer have a thyroid, how can I care for my body to avoid other autoimmune responses?
I wish I had seen this website years ago.
Okay, so let's unpack this question.
I had thyroid cancer.
This person had their thyroid removed.
They assumed they had Hashimoto's before that.
So you can still do it, even though you have no thyroid gland, you had it surgically removed.
You can still test for thyroid antibodies.
If you had your thyroid removed and you're then on scintoroid because you have no thyroid,
you're not producing it.
Thyroid hormone.
You still should be running a thyroid panel to make sure that you're in normal levels of T3 and T4.
In that thyroid panel, you should be requested a full thyroid panel, so not just TSH, T3 and T4,
but you should be requested in reverse T3 and you should be requesting TPO antibodies and thyroid globular antibodies.
So those two antibodies, TPO antibodies and thyroid globular antibodies are going to test whether you have Hashimoto's.
The person still can have Hashimoto's, even though they have thyroid.
And that definition of that is that you have antibodies to those thyroid tissue.
Is that going to cause issues when I don't have a thyroid anymore?
No, it's going to cause less issues.
You're not going to have to worry about damage to the thyroid since that existed anymore.
But at least you'll know whether you had those antibodies.
Many times, even though you don't have a thyroid gland anymore, you'll still have shell presence of those antibodies.
Secondly, you can test for other tissue antibodies, a Syrex array five and a Syrex array seven X test for specific tissue antibodies.
You could also request a antibody test from your medical doctor given your history.
I would think that they would be open to ordering those tests.
You could test for systemic antibodies, A&A antibodies, other systemic antibodies.
There's a patient, their doctor ran a whole bunch of antibody tests for them who's covered under their insurance.
So I think it's wise to request those tests and get those tests run.
Down to this person's question, I've had stomach problems my whole life.
I've been on plant-based in my sense of my surgery.
My endocrinologist told me to go on a gluten-free diet.
Well, it hats off to your endocrinologist.
I tell you right now, because that's an endocrinologist who's reading some literature.
So why would someone recommend a gluten-free diet with somebody with thyroid issues?
And the reason is anybody with thyroid issues, whether it's primary hypothyroidism,
which you were diagnosed with, which you assumed that they'd ever tested for Hashimoto.
So primary hypothyroidism is that this person is showing a combination of elevated TSH, low T3, low T4, some combination thereof.
But no antibodies, their TPO antibodies are negative, the thyroid globular antibodies are negative.
That would be a diagnosis of primary hypothyroidism.
That means you have low thyroid, but you don't have Hashimoto's.
If you have one of those antibodies elevated, that means you fall into the category of Hashimoto's.
So if you have any thyroid issues, primary hypothyroidism, Hashimoto's, or Graves' disease, which is hypothyroid,
you should not be gluten.
Nobody, you don't need to do a gluten test.
It has nothing to do with gluten sensitivity.
It doesn't have to do it with having gliated antibodies.
The reason is that gliated is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So it's not pertaining to having sensitivity to gluten.
It's pertaining to the fact that just from a molecular structure, gliated is a molecular mimic.
There are certain things that we can consume that could be molecular mimics to self-tissue.
Well, gliated is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So every time you eat gluten, you're going to have the ability to stimulate an immune reaction on the thyroid.
So even if the person is primary hypothyroidism, and they are eating gluten, they could end up with Hashimoto's,
and develop antibodies to the thyroid.
So everybody with gluten with thyroid issues, even with thyroid cancer, should not be eating gluten.
Now, I will no longer have a thyroid. How can I care for my body to avoid other autoimmune responses?
And the answer is you want to, in order to avoid developing antibodies to self-tissue,
you want to avoid stimulating these immune system spikes.
So when we have immune system spikes, then that gives us a greater ability to develop antibodies to self-tissue.
So boy, that's hard. How do you get immune system spikes?
You get immune system spikes from having a damage you've got, and developing antibodies to other foods.
So you can have food sensitivities. And every time you eat that food, you create an immune system spike.
Every time you create an immune system spike, you create the ability to develop antibodies to other things.
Toxins in our environment can create immune system spikes, you know, poisons that we're exposed to by breathing and consuming it to highs in food color and et cetera, et cetera.
So damage to the gut, antibodies to food, immune system spikes from toxins are your biggest reasons why you would develop and biotoxins as well.
The biggest reason is why you develop self-antibodies or develop an autoimmune disease.
So trying to live a clean life, basically trying to eat organic, trying to, you know, clean up my diet, maybe wise to run a Syrex array 10.
So if you want, if you think you have an autoimmune disease, then you can run the Syrex self-antibody profiles, which would be the array 5 and the array 7x.
If you think, well, I don't think I have an autoimmune disease, I'm just trying to prevent it, then running Syrex array 10 food sensitivity panel to see,
while am I setting myself up for a possible immune response, these immune fluctuations that could set up possible autoimmune disease.
So Syrex array 10 from a practical standpoint to really diminish and start realizing what I need to do to start healing my gut.